[Music]  once them thank council battles our  place I'm going to the boardwalk coming  are you guys just gonna stay down here  actually just going exploring  where that peninsula across the bay  sounds like an adventure  [Music]  right  I waited but no one showed don't go  accusing we leave a parent here I don't  tell anyone  finally Jason no place was a bus it's  real it's a miracle we just got lucky  tell me what's buried here or I show  Reds in my regular mind in that mess  when you're done playing the bad boys I  promise you pal red he will be in jail  eleven human rumors and my friends have  been talking to the police I think he'll  be more interested in this bread's crazy  and read this allegedly people lie you  need to stand up to  do they comics  this is your origin story  are you gonna grow up to be the good guy  or the bad guy  [Music]  I don't know you should do  you